[Musique]
ces deux photos elles sont prises à 40
ans d'écart d'un côté on est 4 septembre
1957 c'est la photo de la haine
elisabeth et ford qui est la première
noire à entrer dans le lycée blancs de
la ville se fait insulter par une jeune
fille est jeune bryan qui lui dit au
moment précis de la photo rentrer en
afrique
de l'autre côté vous avez les deux mêmes
femmes
quarante ans plus tard on est le 20
septembre 1997 c'est le même photographe
wilkens qui prend la photo mais là c'est
la photo de la réconciliation en
apparence
l'histoire est belle je vais vous
raconter la réalité de l'histoire il ya
une historienne locale
c'est elizabeth jagger wake est blanche
et qui étaient de la région qui était
jeune à l'époque mais qui n'était pas de
ce lycée et qui a une idée un peu folle
qui se dit ça serait formidable si les
deux filles de la photo aujourd'hui des
femmes plutôt âgées quarante ans plus
tard pouvaient se rencontrer si
elisabeth et ford et 11 bryan pouvait
discuter
peut-être même pouvait se réconcilier ce
qui signifierait en vrai qu elisabeth et
ford pardonnerait eisel brian et à
travers ça à ce qu'elle cherche à faire
c'est le fameux pardon de la communauté
noire à l'égard de la communauté blanche
l'idée étant d'effacer un peu un passé
honteux pour pour les blancs américains
du sud des états unis en l'occurrence
ici dans l'arkansas
cette photo est censé donc remplacer la
photo humiliante de du racisme de 1957
et comme la chose est magnifique on va
en faire un port un poster évidemment et
se poster avec les deux femmes devant
le l'enceinte du lycée devant les devant
le lycée de little rock
on va faire en dessous un titre en
énormes réconciliation l'histoire elle
est magnifique
les deux femmes vont commencer à faire
des cours ensemble auprès des jeunes
filles elles vont faire des grandes
émissions de télé ensemble
oprah winfrey le la grande prêtresse de
la confidence parce que l'histoire elle
est belle c'est le happy end que tous
les américains veulent voir notamment
les blancs américains elle se rapproche
vraiment chacune 10 à l'autre que la vie
a dû être difficile
après cette photo il n'y a pas d'
excuses véritable de la part des jeunes
mais il ya tout de même le sentiment que
la certitude que ça a été une vie
difficile pour elisabeth mme elisabeth
aussi est plein d'empathie c'est une
femme extraordinaire à elisabeth est
forte que j'ai pu rencontrer qu'à une
femme qui me une femme avec une immense
empathie et qui est conscient aussi que
ça lui est difficile pour isaac brian de
vivre pendant 40 ans avec cette photo
qui a fait le tour du monde
sauf que l'histoire elle n'est pas finie
elisabeth elle est persuadée qu'elle
époque
en 1957 elle bryan qui n'est pas une
élève du lycée de senjaray school qui
n'est pas une élève du lycée de
l'isolant qu en sous main elle a agité
les provocateurs que ça a été une des
meneuses de l'année scolaire
insupportable que vont vivre
elisabeth et ses huit camarades au lycée
avec des humiliations quotidiennes de la
violence des insultes des crachats tous
les jours tous les jours au lycée
pendant l'année scolaire 57 58 mais à
chaque fois que elisabeth demande
eisel ce qui s'est passé et isole à
chaque fois est très évasive et surtout
dit qu'elle se soucie qu'elle ne se
souvient de rien comme si une espèce
d'amnésie l'avait saisi que le choc
avait été telle est au bout d'un moment
ça commence à saouler elisabeth surtout
qu'elle apprend que dans sa maison et
isole qui a des propos parfois un peu
raciste dans sa famille avec ses parents
et par conséquent elizabeth va à nouveau
s'éloigner des jeunes et elles ne vont
plus jamais se parler
les deux femmes vont au bout de quelques
semaines de quelques mois de
réconciliation vont à nouveau
se séparer et là définitivement mais
l'histoire n'est pas encore finie parce
qu'en 2000 le poster le fameux poster
réconciliation il est épuisé et donc la
question se pose est-ce qu'on peut le
rééditer le poster effet à ce moment là
et elle elle est à fond d'accord parce
que ce poster pour elle c'est sa mémoire
qui est réhabilité mais ce qui est
étonnant c'est qu elisabeth va être
d'accord
elisabeth va dire je suis d'accord pour
que ce poster soit réimprimés et revendu
partout dans le pays
mais à une condition qu'on ajoute un
petit texte en bas du poster et ce petit
texte en bas du poster il est pour elle
il est pour yzeure mais il est surtout
un discours et un message universel
voilà ce qu elisabeth a demandé à voir
inscrit en bas du poster il ne peut y
avoir de véritable réconciliation sans
une reconnaissance sincère du passé
douloureux que nous avons en commun
elisabeth elle était prête à accorder
son pardon elle me l'a dit à condition
que eisel brian reconnaissent
sincèrement ce qu'il s'est passé à
l'époque c'est le sens de ce message
qu'elle écrit en bas le pardon oui on
peut pardonner aux autres mais à
condition qu'il y ait une sincérité dans
les propos échangés et une sincérité
dans la reconnaissance de ce qu'elle
appelle ce passé douloureux